bonjour bienvenue d'un point de vue
continue à nous regarder à commenter
l'actualité avec nous les sujets que
nous avons aujourd'hui devrait vous
faire réagir avec pour commencer cette
désormais célèbre clause molière pour
contrer l'afflux de travailleurs
détachés des patrons de grandes régions
comme laurent wauquiez ou valérie
pécresse l'appliquent
mais elle pourrait bientôt être illégal
on parlera aussi de l'opposition
emmanuel macron au fait quelle
opposition si l'on en croit un récent
sondage elle brille aux abonnés absents
jupiter n'aura pas à descendre de
l'olympe aussitôt pourtant certaines
réformes ne semblent pas forcément à la
hauteur des attentes des français
par exemple celle sur les frais des
députés on pourrait même parler de
réformes cosmétiques pas de révolution
de la moralisation et puis de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique donald trump régale
ses fans et fait feu de tout bois sur
l'accord est sûre les musulmans il
multiplie les rodomontades
la dernière en date traiter le dictateur
nord-coréen lanceur domicile de petits
chevaux malades
bonjour carole barjon merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes chef du service politique
de l'ops et vous venez de publier
déflagration dans le secret d'une
élection impossible un livre
d'entretiens avec patrick stefanini qui
fut le directeur de campagne de françois
fillon
c'est chez robert laffont et à l'ops
vous la couverture cette semaine est un
entretien avec nicolas hulot qui dit
pourquoi je reste
bonjour brice couturier
vous êtes journaliste à france culture
présentateur du tour du monde des idées
et vous est également chroniqueur au
point et vous publiez aussi un livre
intitulé macron le président philosophe
c'est pas rose édition de l'observatoire
ça parle de l'armature intellectuelle du
président et celle qui nourrit son
action politique
il est question de paul ricoeur de
saint-simon et de quelques autres c'est
le livre d'un homme inquiet pour son
pays qui trouve dans l'élection de
macron un motif d'espoir voilà merci
encore d'être avec nous bonjour olivier
duhamel
on a toujours le choix pour vous
présenter juristes politologues
animateur de l'émission médiapolis le
samedi matin sur europe 1 et auteurs
vous de maquereaux et en même temps
c'est paru chez plon avec laurent
bigorgne et à l'ispo dry la présentation
je préfère c'est celle qui avait fait
entrer mollet qui m'a traitée de
redoutables médias politologue et en
face de vous pour mieux débattre cave ou
rose aimée confronter vos idées et
changer quelques piques alexis brézet
directeur des rédactions du figaro
journal existe alors cette clause
molière sera peut-être balayé bientôt
par la justice petit rappel la clause
molière c'est cette disposition qui
exige que les travailleurs détachés
européens sur des chantiers de btp
notamment comprennent le français
leur sécurité est en jeu justifie
laurent wauquiez ou valérie pécresse
discrimination a lancé hier le
rapporteur public devant le tribunal
administratif de lyon demandant
l'annulation de cette clause le conseil
d'état sera appelé à trancher mais alors
qui a raison qui a tort
finalement carole barjon une fois n'est
pas coutume laurent wauquiez valérie
pécresse semblent d'accord ils ont
raison oui d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
laurent wauquiez fait remarquer que le
préfet attaqué en auvergne rhône-alpes
et pas en ile-de-france alors c'est
peut-être le cas depuis mais enfin à
l'origine c'était ça donc on comprenait
pas très bien pourquoi il n'y avait pas
une égalité 2-2 traitement évidemment
laurent wauquiez s'est pas fait faute de
le faire marquer après bon le
gouvernement a quand même
le gouvernement de manuel valls
a décrété cette clause il légal donc
en principe tout le monde devrait être
traité de la même façon sur le fond vous
avez des arguments de certains qui
disent pourquoi au fond à partir du
moment où emmanuel macron on s'attaquait
au travail détachées que cette clause
était un moyen au fond de lutter contre
le travail des tâches et puisqu'il
fallait que les travailleurs en question
par le français
essentiellement je crois et les raisons
invoquées étaient celles de la sécurité
notamment
or emmanuel macron n'a parlé c'est une
mauvaise réponse à une bonne question
alexis c'est une affaire un peu jésuites
donc ça devrait frère pierre olivier
s'était fait un peu 18 on met en avant
la question de sécurité des travailleurs
la question n'est pas là celle de la
sécurité travaillant pour qu'elle puisse
se poser la question c'est de dire il
faut stopper les travailleurs détachés
au départ cet effet par wauquiez et par
pécresse pour lancer un cri d'alarmé en
disant arrêtez ce système fou dont tout
le monde reconnaît depuis des années
qu'il est fou de ces travailleurs qui
sont payés
ceux d'un pic social qui fait que des
travailleurs coûtent beaucoup moins que
c'est beaucoup moins cher pour des
employeurs français d'utiliser de la
main d'oeuvre étrangère parce que les
charges sociales sont pas les mêmes dans
leur pays sur le fond tout le monde
d'accord y compris macron puisque mac on
est parti devant l'europe se bagarrer en
disant il faut revoir ses arrières dh et
c'est ce système est insupportable ça
veut dire qu'il a compris quelque chose
là dessus le problème c'est qu'il a eu
que très très très très partiellement
gain de cause parce que la vérité c'est
que au fond les allemands n'en veulent
pas parce qu'ils ont besoin de main
d'oeuvre que l'épithète en veulent
encore moins parce qu'ils ont besoin
d'envoyer leurs manoeuvres et que donc
l'europe pour ne pas faire perdre la
face à macro ont dit on va revoir le
truc on va prendre quelques années
oui mon limitant en limite la durée
maximale supérieure à la durée moyenne
aujourd'hui de l'emploi des travailleurs
détachés et on exclut les traces donc le
problème est entier et donc la riposte
qui reste évoqué avec ses terrasses et
de trouver ce bien mais biais dont on
peut contester le caractère j'ai dit
mais qui qui décide et répondre un vrai
problème
réponse des v8 d'abord ici buzz et se
trompe je n'ai rien contre les justes et
pénales
et de deux la raison sur le premier
point en tout cas c'est les raisons
invoquées ne sont pas les vraies raisons
c'est une plaisanterie les règles de
sécurité de même que d'autres règles
quand on m'a des travailleurs qui
comprennent pas le français ya
obligation de les afficher dans leurs
mains on est tous assez présent tri donc
en vérité c'est une des gens qui se
battent on sait qu aux molières c'est
d'abord très révélateur c'est plus que
le problème des travailleurs détachés
derrière ça c'est le sait la préférence
nationale qu'on cherche c'est à dire
qu'on cherche à ce que les trois le
travail soient réservés aux salariés
français mais on n'ose pas le dire comme
ça parce que si on disait avec ces mots
on serait exactement dans le discours
du front national du coup on prend le
biais molière feydeau link aux molières
qui peut être contre molière et qui peut
être contre la sécurité
tout ça est d'une hypocrisie sans borne
il faut régler la question des
travailleurs détachés elle n'est en
effet que très partiellement réglé il
faut la régler pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
dumping social
mais c'est pas la cause mollir qui est
la bonne solution qui était une solution
totalement contraire aux principes de
libre circulation qui est l'essence même
du marché unique européen
donc c'est une position anti européenne
neo lepéniste qu on camoufle derrière un
vocabulaire culturel est aussi mise en
quatre préférence ne sais pas du tout
d'accord cela fait préférant la
préférence nationale c'est d'empêcher
les étrangers d'avoir les mains
finalement les mêmes droits que les
français la fonction non c'est pas du
tout ça là aujourd'hui a une préférence
pour l'étranger
non mais c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
vous êtes patron de pme ça vous coûte
moins cher dans de ne faire travailler
un progrès que ça très bien français
donc il s'agit de rétablir l'égalité à
l'exorciste et une parler d'autre chose
vous parlez la valeur des tâches et
supposons que les règles soient
exactement les mêmes ce qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui
et en termes de salaires et en termes de
congé et ans et vous maintenez la clause
moyen pourrait très bien mais la clause
mollir elle ne vise pas à ça elvis qu'on
parle français comme elle fait semblant
de faire semblant que vous l'avez vous
même dit elle fait semblant pour faire
en sorte que ce système qui favorise le
travailleur étranger soit démantelée
elle faisait pas la série b aujourd'hui
à une préférence pour le travail en
polonais ne sais quoi dire quand même il
ya 300 mails faille comme 300 on a quand
même un public du chômage n'y a pas de
raison aucune de dire qu'un travailleur
polonais doit coûter moins cher qu'un
travailleur français d'origine étrangère
et le passage on va pas fuir tous là
dessus mais il ya deux sujets différents
il ya le sujet travailleurs détachés là
est ce que les règles doivent être les
mêmes et puis il ya d'autres gens qui
lisent travailleurs détachés ou pas même
si les règles sont les mêmes
il faut la préférence nationale le
travail dont les français niveau q
l'essence de la clause molière n'est pas
du premier ordre mais du second
puisqu'elle exige qu'on parle français
quelles que soient les règles par
ailleurs sur les sharks alors de voir
qu'ils sont sincères en invoquant site
ford et je regarde ce qu'elles ne le
sont pas ils sont hypocrites mais la
clause c'est ça ils sont pas de la même
hypocrisie que celle que vous décrivez
salle puisque leur train de vie peut
créer tout dépend de savoir si on a
envie de payer nos maisons plus cher au
moins cher il est évident que quand on
fait venir des travailleurs roumains qui
coûte deux ou trois fois moins cher que
des travailleurs français ont fait des
raids ont fait des économies sur les
budgets des bons par ailleurs il ya un
autre problème c'est un problème
oui mais faith alors c'est qu'on n'a pas
le budget du chômage de la protection
sociale a voulu payer en impôts que vous
payez pas pour peut-être raison mais je
pense que sur tout ce qui nous a servi
de leçon c'est la sphère du breakbeat
car en effet ce qui s'est passé en
grande bretagne c'est précisément un
afflux extravagant de travailleurs venus
d'europe de l'est qui ont cassé les prix
et les gaz les prix du marché sur le
marché du travail et c'est vraiment
quand on voit les sondages en grande
bretagne et qu'il est très clair que le
vote sur le brésil a été provoquée par
cet afflux très massif de travailleurs à
bas à bas prix et prom faible protection
sociale venus d'europe centrale et aussi
pour la langue douala ont été très mal
d'entendre notant que l'anglais dans les
rues non la suite de tron policiers en
fait moi j'étais sur place et randy
beaucoup en angleterre que le problème
c'est que on préfère employer des
polonais parce que leur anglais est très
compréhensible pour les patrons que des
jeunes anglais dont on ne comprend
absolument plus l'idiome et qui parle un
anglais tels tellement défectueux durant
quelques heures
non non non c'est la vérité je t'assure
jedier enseigner et je déjeune ensemble
et on les comprend très malheur que les
jeunes sont les mêmes sauf à ce que leur
anglais et beaucoup beaucoup pour que
plus articulée dans mes seize elle de
plaisanterie mais c'est vrai enfin enfin
reste l'accueil shakespeare
c'est là que shakespeare non mais c'est
vrai que il faut tenir compte des leçons
d'une histoire toute récente et le
breakbeat nous a avertis contre les
risques qu'il ya à multiplier la
libéralisation du marché du travail
jusqu'au point où effectivement on peut
se trouver face enfin où un patron peut
avoir le choix entre un boucher un
ressortissant locale qui bénéficiera
d'une protection sociale sérieuse et un
roumain ou un polo mais qu'on comptera
15 pierre et qu'on ne protégera pas sur
le plan social donc il ya et mais encore
une fois n'oubliez pas vous les
consommateurs qui nous regardaient que
si vous refusez les travailleurs
roumains sur les chantiers vous allez
payer plus cher les lycées et les
hôpitaux que nous sommes en train de
construire avec l'argent public
alors c'est une question qui agite les
réseaux sociaux mais juan merouane magic
qui nous a rejoint effectivement clause
molière tout de suite c'est direct je
pensais qu'ils étaient pour et ben en
fait non ils sont plutôt contre vous
regardez bien sûr certains internautes
qui sont pour moi j'ai lu surtout des
personnes qui étaient contre angers
notamment alain privat qui nous dit la
clause molière n'est pas une solution
pérenne mais au fond c'est un moyen une
possibilité finalement pour limiter le
flux d'étrangers non ci est ce qui nous
dit évidemment qu'elle va être annulé
cette clause pour moi c'est illégal
comme mesure mais bon on est dans la
communication pure etienne roger nous
dit il y un choix à faire soit on
favorise les échanges européens où on en
accepte les contraintes et on en tire
aussi les bénéfices soit on joue la
concurrence entre pays européens et à
mon avis dans l'histoire ce sera nous
les perdons on a aussi du choc
combien premier offre donc pas de vendre
la maîtrise de l'anglais est
discriminatoire
oui mais un moment un choix est une
discrimination le problème de savoir si
le motif est justifié demander à des
personnes venant travaillant ici de
comprendre un minimum ce qui ne me
semble pas aberrant poil à gratter de
retour nous dit mesure totalement démago
à la donald trump juste pour satisfaire
un électorat plus extrémiste et attirer
le front national c'est un peu ce que
vous disiez olivier duhamel
et enfin enfin pour finir j'ai le marin
704 qui nous dit heureusement qu'il n'en
demande pas aux français qui travaillent
à l'étranger de parler la langue du pays
ou bien à laurent wauquiez de prononcer
quelques mots en anglais ou en allemand
merci beaucoup on note effectivement le
rappeler il ya devant manuel macron a
remis cette directive en cause devant
l'europe fait un petit détour sur le
mode de scrutin et le annonce d'un
scrutin national d'un retour aux quotas
national pour les élections européennes
c'est purement une manoeuvre politique
pour emmanuel macron la fois d'un
footing mais c'est du bon sens
évidemment ça les arrange parce que il
n'a pas mis les 1 milliard de tête de
liste au site autrefois il un système où
il y avait huit listes il faut les
trouver huit têtes de listes est bon les
gens de on marchera pas connu à ce point
qu'on trouve lui qui adore pour mener
les huit listes
donc ça les arrange ça arrange au
passage aussi le front national et ça
arrange au passage aussi mélenchon mais
c'est quand même le bon sens et histoire
de liste régionale qui est des régions
qui ne ressemble à rien qu'ils sont des
bourses à l'est de l'île jusqu'à nantes
des goudes région qui dans lesquels jean
se reconnaissaient absolument pas pour
élire des députés qui sont censés être
députés qui représentent la france n'est
pas une région c'est justement on n'est
pas justement dans le système de
l'europe des régions et de ce point de
vue les républicains qui dénotait des
gens du parti républicain qui dénonça
parce que ça les arrange pas évidemment
c'est en contradiction avec ceux qui
pensent parce que quand on est contre
l'europe des régions et pour l'europe
des nations
on est pour une liste pour une liste
nationale tripatouillage il est
simplement non je pense que je pense
qu'effectivement l'expérience a montré
que les députés européens n'ont
absolument aucun rapport avec leur
région d'origine
il représente il représente la france et
représente absolument pas une région
donc c'est son nom mais ce que je
souhaite surtout c'est que les listes
européennes aux prochaines élections
européennes reflète des tendances
politiques paneuropéenne et pas
française quand sortent un peu du
républicain et des socialistes il ya il
ya des courants politiques que européen
les écologiques les écologistes libéraux
des conservateurs tout ce que voulait
des souverainistes mais qu' ils se
comptent à l'échelle de l'europe et que
et qu'on arrête ce caractère de
nationalisation d'élections européennes
qui n'ont rien à voir avec nous
nous histoire franco-française vous qui
connaissez vous êtes favorable à
l'inclusion des ex député européen
britannique dans le quota s'ils sont
sortis non mais en revanche fait faire
des listes transnationales à partir de
ses sièges
écoutez c'est compliqué je suis
intellectuellement pour politiquement
prudent c'est à dire que moi c'est
toujours le vide est allée puis ce qui
est faisable aujourd'hui je suis pas sûr
que ça change énormément de choses je
suis très pour les listes nationales
pour une raison très simple c'est que
bien qu'étant très demandés en
arithmétique je crois que 5 x 8 ça fait
quarante bon en rui région émettons
front national les républicains en
marche ce que deviendra le parti
socialiste et mélenchon 5 grandes forces
politiques on peut pas faire 40 débat on
peut pas faire 40 débat différence enfin
peut pas faire lui débat avec 40
personnes c'est juste pas possible donc
plus pour le simple fait qu'il y ait une
vraie campagne européenne qu'on a une
petite chance qui est un débat national
sur l'europe pour cette simple raison là
il faut des listes nationales
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a inventé les
listes dans les grandes régions parce
que ç'a toujours été inventé par le
pouvoir en place à deux reprises
d'ailleurs puisqu'on m'a fait des
allers-retours dans le mode de scrutin
pour essayer de le plus en plus possible
dofus possible diluer le résultat des
élections parce qu'on pensait qu'elle
serait mauvaise pour le pouvoir c'est ça
la vraie mère et front national parce
qu'il est un front national mené par un
win le pen frappe fait plus qu'un que
huit petites listes du front national
pour ce que je dis donc on replante
mettre d'accord les deux balades de
savoir qu'on soit d'accord
les deux arguments sont justes et là
c'est d'ailleurs assez étonnant mais
alors qu'elle est derrière cahier
d'arrière pensées de macron dont on
verra s'il réussit ou pas un rien penser
de mâcon c'est de se dire que il peut
être à l'origine de la seule vraie liste
pro européenne et qui peut pour ça
grignoter assez loin à gauche et à
droite parce que le parti sis à lezoux
ce qui est dans restera ou ce qu'il en
revient bas est très divisé sur la
question européenne
ils raisonnent plus ils sont très
divisés sur la question en tête et c'est
vrai que s'il arrive dans la foulée des
déclarations qu'on fait ou qu'on a
attribué à juppé
s'il arrive a ajouté un en marche des
socialistes européens et des
républicains européen
sa liste arrivera en tête et il aura
réussi des élections normalement pouvoir
perd un dernier mot sur ce point qu'on
va passer à vivre en fait parce que
disait alain juppé à un moment donné en
disant qu'il fallait
comment dire il fallait ou bene de goût
de l'homme entre les deux bouts de
l'hommelet lui garder le milieu et donc
je pense que ça c'est effectivement
sûrement le pari de macron pour les
européennes
la seule chose c'est que un certain
nombre de députés républicains public
info remarquer qu ensuite il faut quand
même choisir un groupe pour siéger à
strasbourg et que là il faudra quand
même qu emmanuel macron et là il ya le
ppe et le pse est bon ensuite y'a les
libéraux donc le côté est de droite et
de gauche des manuels macron qui a bien
marché en france jusqu'à présent toute
la force et la strasbourg compliqué à
strasbourg parce que oui mais pas des
socialistes et la droite et où est-ce
qu'ils vont aller d un marginal donc
l'idée des transnationales de ce qu on
aura le temps de voir parce que c'est en
où est passé l'opposition emmanuel
macron box style dans le vide
oui si l'on en croit un sondage est là
pour bfm tv
plus de 4 français sur 10 estiment
qu'aucun parti politique n'est un
adversaire de taille pour le président
de la république
même la france insoumise rejoint presque
le rang des lilliputiens
ce n'est plus macro jupiter c'est le
géant du l'hiver alors carole barjon la
droite n'a pas encore écrit son avenir
comme semble le penser patrick stefanini
dans le livre que vous avez écrit avec
lui elle a pas de contre-programme
emmanuel macron pour l'instant non
d'abord c'est un petit peu tôt quand
même on sait que quand même après une
défaite pareille
des fêtes puisqu'elle n'était pas elle
n'était pas présente au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle donc c'est
quand même un séisme donc d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'on a appelée notre livre
déflagration c'est parce que voilà il ya
des effets qui se produisent sur le long
terme
donc c'est un peu tôt pour qu'elles se
soient reconstruites et qu'elle est un
contre au programme j'imagine que
évidemment le propos de laurent wauquiez
en se faisant élire à la présidence des
républicains puisqu'il semble bien que
c'est une sera élu centre problème c'est
précisément de reconstruire de redonner
une armature intellectuelle idéologique
à la droite mais tout ça ça viendra
ça viendra plus tard le problème c'est
que la droite est déjà très morcelé on
voit bien enfin les constructif qui font
des sous-groupes agir
valérie pécresse de son côté xavier
bertrand qui a l'air aussi d'être sur
son aventin dans sa région hôte france
bon donc il va je pense que peut-être
même avant de au fond
d'élaborer un contre-programme il va
déjà devoir aller rechercher un peu tout
les ouailles et les brebis égarées et
évidemment essayer de ramener des
électeurs du front national bien entendu
olivier duhamel
on entend souvent effectivement une fois
laurent wauquiez lui il va réussir à
rassembler à c'est une vérité c'est
difficile à dire ça va dépendre ci
parvient élaboré je dirais pas dans le
bon sens du mot dans le sens positif du
mot une école une idéologie un peu
cohérente entre le front national et
macro et ceux qui le soutiennent puisque
bons jours neuville est plutôt dans la
rhétorique
alors il a une rhétorique la droite
c'est pas un gros mot il faut être
vraiment de droite il a une rhétorique
il n'y a pas de sujet tabou de la durée
théorique messieurs européen mais je
vais une autre europe ça mais tout ça ce
sont des mots le problème est qu'il faut
qu'ils fassent quelque chose de
consistant notamment qu'il distingue du
front national parce que si vous
regardez bien papa au front national il
est absolument ferme sur un point qui
répète tout le temps jamais d'alliance
jamais d'éloges jamais d'alliance mais
il critique jamais à part sur les
histoires d'euros et où il critique
jamais ni position du front national de
frontalement sur l'immigration sur
l'islam sur d'autres sujets or il faut
qu'il s'en distingue pour rassembler sa
droite
il faut qu'il s'en distingue et à ce
moment là pour le dire très vite et
autrement
qu'est-ce qui a besoin de forces
politiques pour se remettre à exister et
à convaincre
elle a besoin d'être incarné par un
homme elle le sera au lendemain
d'élections de bloquer ce problème la
base est résolue il sera le légitime
chef de l'opposition
de droite au pouvoir et puis elle a
besoin d'un minimum d'idéologie
cohérente derrière lesquels on se
retrouve
et ça ça restera à faire les deux jambes
alexis je vois quelque chose qu'il faut
donc que wauquiez doit surtout pas faire
cinq rôles des conseils le premier truc
c'est d'ailleurs comme ça parce que
c'est grâce il faut réunir il faut il
chercher pierpoljak valérie pécresse a
dit bertrand gille autres ça ne sert à
rien c'est pas comme c'est en allant les
chercher qui les fera venir
c'est en créant par sa cohérence oui une
adhésion on les oblige à des électeurs
il le fera il le fera pas mais c'est le
seul moyen de faire venir les chapeaux à
plumes c'est si simple que ça gagne ils
reviendront
sinon elles viendront jamais pour leur
pouvoir prétend qu'il veut ils
reviendront pas le deuxième proche je
suis en accord avec losier quand il dit
qu'il faut qu'ils se dotent d'un corpus
idéologique
oui mais je pense que la pierre de
touche de ce corpus est pas du tout la
position visées du frontal
il faut surtout qu'ils se gardent bien
d'évoquer sa vie puisque évidemment il
va se brouiller avec les uns avec les
autres
il faut qu'il fasse revenir les
électeurs du front national et ce campus
et sur les sujets de fond c'est là je
vous rejoins en dix ans derrière les
mots qu'est-ce qui veut vraiment fait
sur l'immigration qu'est ce qu'il veut
vraiment faire sur les travailleurs
détachés
qu'est ce qu'il veut vraiment faire sur
l'éducation et là on verra en quoi si ça
l'est en quoi c'est différent de ce que
propose mâcon et en quoi si salée en
quoi ces défenses du front national
c'est pas la positionnement tactique
vis-à-vis d'un parti c'est sur les
thèmes essayer de faire revenir les gens
qui verront bien qu'il est différent des
autres désolé on est d'accord
pas tout à fait plus que vous croyez moi
t'as pas tout à fait le même chemin
l'objectif est le même
alors j'ai effectivement il a peut-être
encore un peu trahi parce que le
baromètre kantar sofres pour le figaro
magazine donnent une cote de confiance
qui repart à la hausse pour emmanuel
macron et notamment dans l'électorat et
sympathisants républicains alex est ce
que vous avez vu la scène et au front
national aussi
si vous avez la scène de macron avec la
halle avec la jeune la jeune femme
marocaine
c'est inouï la semaine dernière c'est
une scène incroyable où elle lui dit je
voudrais des papiers est lui très
gentiment lui dit mais non faut rentrer
chez vous vous avez passé pendant je
mens mais rentrez chez vous je vous dise
à la france wine votre père lei
généreuse avec votre père mais
franchement vous serez bien au maroc
mais le signal qu'envoie ya 13 ça est
incroyable
imaginons que sarkozy ait dit ça etc il
ya un message là et ça veut dire que
macron au delà du libéralisme économique
en tout cas en paroles a pris en compte
a certes une certaine attente de la
droite on sent serge que ça la droite
classique que sur le front national et
même d'ailleurs de l'électorat populaire
de la gauche
donc là il faut cette phrase-là six
contre six comptes s'il agit dans le
sens de cette phrase la secte aux droits
qui vont venir le duo dany sur les
passeurs sont africains ça allait dans
le même sens mais là le discours de
ouagadougou mardi
c'est pas nouveau parce que de pont
pendant toute sa campagne électorale on
s'est aperçu que macro n'arrêtait pas de
dire que les réfugiés
bénéficiant de l'asile politique et les
migrants économiques c'était deux
réalités différentes et qui avait aucune
raison de garder les migrants
économiques
c'est un discours qui fait scandale à
gauche oh c'est celui que ma compta tenu
pendant toute sa campagne électorale
donc il n'ya pas de revirement chez
makro simplement je crois beaucoup de
gens n'avaient pas qu'on ne l'avait pas
entendu en réalité est évidemment dans
le feu de la campagne électorale
énormément de commentateurs en
particulier à droite avait tendance à
voir en macro tout à fait autre chose
que ce qu'il était en faisant un
parangon du multiculturalisme alors qui
le condamnait en paroles mais
malheureusement il y avait des zones et
quand il n'ya pas de culture française
et quand il n'ya pas de dylan il a écrit
à plusieurs reprises je suis contre le
moustique jones je suis pour
l'intégration il l'a dit il l'a dit
répété la culture française c'est un
signal à un peu compliqué entend
récolter assez vite après c'était une
connerie et la collation crimes contre
l'humanité là il le redit panafricain il
ya des rires dans la colonisation il dit
pas la sensation d'un crime contre vous
et surtout la version européenne où il
ya la colonisation française ce record
51 eur pour revenir sur les partis
politiques et ce qu'il en reste
il faut pas oublier qu'on a vécu une
conflagration enfin il espèce de bombes
atomiques qui a explosé en mai en juin
dernier
donc s'imaginer que les partis
politiques les vieux partis de
gouvernement qui à eux deux ont fait 26
% des voix au premier tour des élections
présidentielles vont repartir comme
comment l'an 40 parti socialiste est
parti et les républicains moi je sais
que je suis étonné c'est qu'il reste
encore quelque chose qui s'appelle le
parti socialiste d'ailleurs il est en
train de vendre son
ce n'était pas quelqu'un les
républicains sur les 100 députés qui
compte à l'assemblée nationale ce qui
est vraiment très peu beaucoup soient en
fait des mac revient donc ce que
j'attends moi c'est de nouveau parti
politique c'est ridicule de vouloir
continuer avec le parti socialiste et le
parti des républicains
les néo gaulliste qu'est ce que ça veut
dire être au néo gaulliste au 21ème
siècle voyons parti socialiste qui
effectivement d'après sondages au dos le
figaro plus de trois quarts des français
fabien oui estiment que le la
disparition du ps n'est pas est
envisagée donc l'enterrement est en tout
cas vous voulez vous qu'on leur répète
toute la journée et on vienne le faire
encore là dans un unanimisme que je ne
partage pas que le parti socialiste est
mort moi je suis pas du tout convaincu
que le parti se sait investi est mort je
suis convaincu que les partis politiques
doivent se transformer très profondément
et que ça vaut pour le parti
conservateur comme pour le labor au
royaume-uni ça vaut pour les
républicains les démocrates aux états
unis et ça vaut pour les républicains et
pour le parti socialiste en france 2 l'a
dit elle vient aussi d'en sont
complètement incapable si d'un autre
côté de macron réussi formidablement si
son mouvement devient le premier
mouvement politique français
si tout ça se produit en effet le parti
socialiste disparaîtra donc il peut
disparaître mais c'est pas évident que
tout ça se produise
avec des si comme vous dites
effectivement toujours dans les temps
les types de sondages et autres on voit
le parti socialiste qui ces fonds est-ce
que la candidature par exemple luc
carvounas ça fait pas franchement le nom
merci de me suggérer ce terme
est ce que cette voie là c'est
typiquement le genre de mini mini
événement dans les choux
alors bon gars carvounas ya quand même
pas que lui il ya najat vallaud belkacem
qui est inexistante en fait d'accord pas
d'accord
oui mais finira par y aller épatant pour
le parti de finir vous pourrez pas
l'abri
l'agriculteur dessus à boulet rouge la
gauche aime bien quand la droite à des
structures donc ça lui ferait du bien
elle représenterait quand même quelque
chose d'un peu différent de ce qu'on a
eu l'habitude donc ce serait là le foll
pour vous après je pense qu'il faut pas
on n'est que quelques mois après
l'élection de maxit aux cinq ans c'est
long
tout se passe tu les choses changent
tellement vite on l'a vu la fin il ya un
an la présidentielle qu est-ce qu on se
racontait les uns les autres et puis on
a vu ce qui est arrivé
donc c'est à dire le ps est mort les
républicains sont morts macron va être
élu comme tout le monde et dit
aujourd'hui
bien malin qui pourrait dire ça alors on
parmi les autres commentaires on avait
vu françois hollande qui avait ressurgi
un petit peu par mais avec des critiques
et autres et puis là et quand ils
réapparaissent et de nouveau sinon mais
il a quand même on joue un peu sur les
mots parce que parti socialiste elle
pour l'inconnu
oui il est celui là il est mort où je
veux dire comme force dominante
expression de la social démocratie qui
est quand même très mal en point
ça veut pas dire que tout ça
effectivement n'existera plus mais en
tout cas ce sont des forces qui pour le
moment se cherche d'abord parce qu'il y
en a aussi qui sont partis du côté de
de macron donc effectivement si macron
déçoit tout ça pourra peut-être se
reconstituer enfin pour le moment on n'a
pas l'impression que ça prenne le chemin
et dans les candidats qu'on voit poindre
puisque certains ne sont pas déclarés au
parti socialiste ça fait pas un oui ça
fait pas franchement ça fait pas
franchement rêver c'est vrai que najat
vallaud belkacem si elle se déclare et
oui c'est une tête de turc de la droite
elle route la gauche aime bien en
principe les têtes de pioche de la
droite mais moi je crois que justement
on n'est plus tout à fait dans ces
moments là parce que
je pense que marcel gauchet disait très
bien pendant la campagne présidentielle
que les français et ce qui expliqué pour
partie le succès d' emmanuel macron
c'est que ils se sont décidés aussi ils
ont voté contre les sectarismes en
partie pour d'autres raisons aussi mais
aussi contre ça et pardon mais najat
vallaud belkacem
elle incarne un peu le sectarisme du
parti socialiste si elle a même
contraints l'école ça c'est votre prisme
effet de mettre la table finalement
c'était effectivement ya un an j'ai là
françois hollande renoncer à se
présenter à l'élection
hier où quelqu un peu plus tôt il a
effectivement fait et et s'est vu
récompensé par le prix de l'humour
politique c'est de l'entendre son oeuvre
pour lens at il dit lui même il doit
voir barack obama oui mais surtout il
prononce un ministre nous avons de 800
étudiants à bordeaux où je crois ce
week-end alors là on savait que va-t-il
dire que le maquereau langue sa place
après ses petits
à la faveur de l'été puis ces petites
phrases et critique on l'a vu réémerger
comme un opposant et puis puis ça s'est
un petit peu ça fait pschitt
il aurait une vraie telle affaire qui
seraient des vrais ressorts de la
fonction présidentielle le cas françois
hollande c'est à dire comment est ce
qu'un homme aussi intelligent aussi féru
de politique aussi sympathie a pu à ce
point là ne pas réussir à incarner la
fonction présidentielle
et comme en pire encore lorsque
l'histoire a connu des moments des
dramatiques et lui a offert des fenêtres
dans lesquelles il incarnait totalement
deletang d'ordinaire revenu à nouveau
être incapable de rester dans ce costume
c'est très intéressant par rapport à la
personnalité de hollande mais au delà de
ça c'est très intéressant sur ce que
l'on attend en france d'un président de
la république
vous êtes d'accord brice couturier sur
ce manque d'incarnation la wii mais je
me souviens de l'excellente interview
que françois hollande avait donné un
mois avant qu'ils se déclarent non
candidat dans la revue le débat où il
expliqué en quoi sa fonction était
devenu impossible comme il avait été élu
finalement sans majorité qu'il avait dû
faire c'était une interview passionnante
ce type est effectivement très
intelligent et il est très bien réfléchi
à son échec en réalité c'est pathétique
mais que voulez vous quand on se
présente c'est le problème des partis
politiques c'est que le parti socialiste
était fait de deux tendances absolument
inconciliables entre elles une quêté
sociale libérale et qu'effectivement a
rejoint macron et qui a fait son succès
il y en avait une autre les frondeurs
que les mails les médias ont longtemps
on tente un mis en
en lumière qui aujourd'hui représente
plus rien très intéressant c'est la
disparition des font des rondes pendant
pendant trois mois on entendu par les
codes ces frondeurs que des 35 assemblée
nationale mais qui semblait incarner la
vraie gauche
cette vraie gauche a été totalement
balayé par les élections mais elle a
plombé le quinquennat de hollande
et cet essai devrait gauche avaient été
installés par sa rivale la maire de
lille martine aubry qui les avait
installés là pour pour pour feinter
hollande faut quand même rare c'est pour
ça qu'il faut que le ps est prêt d'être
des gens il a réfléchi à toutes les
causes de son échec
sauf à lui-même oui c'est un motard à 6
ans qui est au coeur de nos
responsabilités mais quand il va nous
expliquer aujourd'hui puisqu'il l'a dit
je n'ai pas perdu
je n'y a pas perdu s'est pas présenté et
enfin en être à ce point là dans le déni
et dire il s'en fallait d'un poil et si
je m'étais présenté ça veut dire quand
même qu'en dépit de toute son
intelligence il n'a pas compris le rejet
total dont ils faisaient continue de
faire l'objet qui a compris le rejet
total dans l'histoire
est-ce qu est-ce que jusqu'à a compris
ce le rejet dont il a été l'objet avant
82 les mois qui ont suivi
est-ce que même de gaulle a compris le
rejet dont elle a été l'objet est ce
qu'il est possible à un homme politique
de comprendre le rejet donc je crois que
c'est la limite de tout au bien sûr mais
on peut au moins on analyser à ça alors
on se trouve des excuses et d'armé ne
rien voir du tout je pense que malgré
tout jusqu'à avec un fini par comprendre
qu'ils s'étaient peu défaut il a
considéré que les français s'étaient
trompés que c'était un malentendu qui
n'avait pas bu sont le vrai giscard qui
était différente mais il a bien vu que
même un malentendu entre ce qu'on avait
perdu
sarkozy est très lucide finalement sur
son échec et a fait bien s'était bien
rendu compte je le trouvais injuste il
et j'ai fait le boulot quand on disait
qu'il avait pas failli et chers écolos
mais jusque mai mais il avait assez bien
vu il a très bien vu ce qui s'était
passé françois fillon carrés par jour là
dessus justement quand même là dessus
et puis tous ces gens ils pouvaient
s'appuyer sur un score qu'il avait
réalisé quand même dans une élection
face à leurs adversaires
et ensuite du coup ça pouvait leur
permettre de dire voilà la gauche
n'était pas majoritaire où la droite où
la droite était mis enfin bref foule
inverse et c'est là le problème de
françois hollande c'est qu'il n'a même
pas réussi à pouvoir se représenter ce
qui est quand même un cas de figure très
différentes
le pas s'être présenté du 1er prix un
autre vraiment unique
c'est ma fait que benoît hamon candidat
du parti socialiste et françois fillon
le candidat du parti républicain donc
les deux rives de gouvernement ne soit
même pas député alors à l heure qu il
est n'est plus représenté enfin alain
était battu carrément et l'autre ne même
pas pu se représenter
donc ça montre bien que les partis de
gouvernement aujourd'hui ce n'est plus
rien et c'est sale et françois fillon
n'a pas autre chose
mais oui enfin il était mort politique
passion très intéressant comme le
désagrément hollande
il était mort politiquement mais s'en
est aussi ainsi bien lu votre livre qui
n'a pas compris quand même lui non plus
françois fillon qu'il a quand même une
tendance à avoir une explication
totalement exogènes qu'on peut quasi
complotistes ou bien sûr et vous
précisément senans 16 ans livre son ex
directeur de campagne explique bien
qu'il n'y a pas de complot et que ce
sont des raisons à la fois il
yal'affaire pénélope mais aussi il ya
des choses qui viennent de plus loin sur
l'état de la droite le projet etc mais
qu'ensuite il ya aussi la personnalité
de fillon qui ne meurt au fond un
mystère encore aujourd'hui pour beaucoup
de gens et même pour lui
donc et donc c'est pour ça que c'était
une campagne totalement ce qu'on apprend
pas ce que je comprends mais aussi qui
rappelle jamais c'est ça moi je me suis
comment est ce que dans le pays où des
gens sont tellement investiguer suivi
dans le détail et où il a pu traverser
si longtemps sans que des faits aussi
extravagant été portés à notre
connaissance
alors est-ce que les leçons aussi des
échecs et des de la campagne n'ont pas
été tirées ces sur la transparence et la
moralisation de la vie politique c'est
5000 de 372 euros et 80 centimes le
montant de l'enveloppé mensuels alloués
aux députés pour leurs frais elle ne va
pas changer députés qui seront au pire
ou au mieux contrôler une fois pendant
leur mandat alors sans faire
d'antiparlementarisme primaire la
moralisation de la vie politique est
elle vraiment en marche
on peut s'interroger le président de
l'assemblée nationale françois de rugy
assuré lui ce matin sur europe 1 que
tout avait changé
en l'écoutant on a vraiment changé le
système puisque 1 on fait une liste des
frais autorisé ou interdit
oui ensuite la biologie les la garde
d'enfants non pourquoi pas la garde
d'enfants drian mais c'était un débat
c'était un débat les députés qui ont de
jeunes enfants ont des frais de garde
mais la majorité moi j'ai consulté
l'ensemble des groupes parlementaires la
déontologue de l'assemblée ont dit non
ce ne sont pas des frais de mandat nous
avons dit de façon claire nette précise
les députés doivent garder tous les
justificatifs ça provoquait quelques
sourires de ce côté c'est que j'avais
peut-être se dit serein on a trois ferme
ça prouve que notre dame et la vie reste
de qualité reste des cas là parce que
dans toutes les entreprises du monde et
on doit faire garder leurs enfants c'est
pas des frais professionnels
sinon il peut y avoir des crèches
d'entreprises alors c'est le seul à
l'assemblée mais plus que françois de
rugy veut développer et quand même si
milan aurait d'accord dit à l'assemblée
donc on va pas en plus payer les
visiteurs quand même c'est quoi
couturier de l'aveuglément effectivement
un sentiment d'impunité
c'est encore écouter c'est une nouvelle
fois une réforme macro de mâcon qui
s'arrêtent à mi chemin de milieu du gué
exactement c'était bien parti il a
encore c'est comme pour la réforme du
code du travail à mon sens c'était bien
parti mais ça s'arrête à mi chemin oui
ce qui est insupportable si vous voulez
c'est que les députés ne soient pas
soumis comme les salariés des
entreprises ou du service public à un
contrôle de leurs feuilles propres
officiel que les frais pour les 16 soit
remboursé mon dieu c'est normal nous
autres journalistes moi pas mais la
plupart d'entre nous sont remboursés
pour leurs frais de taxi par exemple
mais sur justificatif
ce qui est scandaleux si vous laissez
mais pas tous mais ce qui est scandaleux
c'est elle qui régnait jusqu'à présent
c'est-à-dire le fait que les députés et
sénateurs ne devraient compte ne devait
de rendre compte de rien de ce qui était
leur frais professionnels
là si j'ai bien compris il ya plus 600
euros par mois qui ne sont pas sur
justificatif tout le reste est fait mais
c'est plus compliqué que ça j'ai bien si
j'ai bien compris c'est que ça avait été
évoquée mais finalement non on leur
demande juste éventuellement en cas de
contrôle de pouvoir produire les
justificatifs fait c'est pas salé des
justifications
non non c'est à dire qu stéréo il va y
avoir des contrôles aléatoires comme ils
appellent ça il faut maintenant
conserver ces justificatifs au cas où on
ferait l'objet de contrôles
ce qui n'était pas le cas bon donc
effectué mort il faut quand même avoir
des justificatifs et on a dit la fable
de dépenses ne serait plus exposé levet
du frais professionnels et que d'autres
dépenses qui ne sont plus exclues comme
la loi quand elle part donc oui moi je
voudrais juste dire un mot franchement
si je pense que peut-être que j'ai
choqué atrocement les gens qui nous
écoutent
je pense que c'est vraiment pas ça le
problème enfin si on lui dit si cette
question moralisation politique c'est
pas les soirs des frais des députés à
l'assemblée il ya des problèmes avait
l'assemblée c'est pas du rôle des
députés
c'est pas la question de savoir quelles
sont leurs frais ne me semble-t-il
section savoir à quoi ils servent que
les moyens criant pour exercer leur
mission tout ça moi c'est cette
histoire-là jeu
c'est bien sa frappe les esprits il ya
les vraies questions jalons avec 6 puis
à les questions qui heurtent les gens
c'est pas toujours les bonnes questions
et d'une part donc premier problème et
se passionne pour des sujets qui sont
pas les plus importants mais c'est comme
ça deuxième problème
brice teinturier raison coûté des sites
brice couturier qui s'est excusé excuses
et alain duhamel
voilà 15 ans alors donc le vrai problème
c'est que pour il a raison que c'est une
réforme à mi chemin mais cette réforme à
mi-chemin pour les députés ou en tout
cas un très grand montre c'est une
révolution considérable c'est une
réforme à 90%
comment on peut pas dépenser comme on
veut le signe d'une balle mais qu'est ce
que c'est que cette histoire et pour
l'opinion c'est une réforme elle est
objectivement à mi chemin mais il ya un
monde entre ce que les députés pensent
qu est ce qu on fait comme effort on
peut même plus dépenser notre argent
tranquille est ce que pensent les
français mais pourquoi vous faites pas
comme tout le monde mais c'est ce qui
explique d'ailleurs la donc la distance
mais mais mais mais qui est là depuis 25
ans parce que quand d'aucuns s'émouvait
un peu que les députés puissent cotiser
double ou triple sur leur retraite à une
époque qu'ils aient les prêts
immobiliers à taux zéro etc
quand on faisait cette remarque là on se
faisait traiter de démago de populiste
et c'est donc le problème c'est qu'ils
ont toujours un temps de retard sur le
coin et donc olivier duhamel la raison
pour les parlementaires aujourd'hui
c'est dans leur tête un énorme progrès
mais pour les gens oui ça ne paraît
juste assez normal quoi ces cosmétiques
est là on va passer maintenant de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique le calme
relatif de donald trump a été de courte
durée
le président américain a d'abord réagi
sobrement au tir d'un missile
nord-coréen mais pour mieux se déchaîner
par la suite ça a été un festival il a
traité le dictateur de pyonyang de
chiots malades sic poppy en anglais
après little rock et man
puis l'art tweets et des vidéos
antimusulman posté par britten firth
britten firth et un micro parti
britannique d'extrême droite il s'est
assis attiré les foudres de theresa may
pour ces faits que nous mais il a
aussitôt répliqué au premier ministre
britannique en balançant occupe toi de
ton terrorisme islamique
alors avec tout ça on va juste écouter
donald trump c'était hier dans le
missouri et puis on en reparle
[Rires]
et je check paris c'est que papy ça ne
vole pas très haut
brice couturier alors que le monde
entier se demande si on va pas se
prendre la foule nucléaire sur la tête
bon il en coût il faut quand même
remarquer que d'un côté on a affaire à
une dictature sanglante épouvantable
héréditaire le premier le première
dynastie communiste héréditaire le grand
père le fils et le petit-fils qui
fabrique des armes nucléaires alors
qu'ils sont engagés à ne pas s'en faire
et ses nombreux motards comme le fait le
font trop souvent les médias français et
occidentaux en général
renvoyé dos à dos la première puissance
militaire de la planète qui a assuré
jusqu'à une époque récente celle d'obama
une espèce de garantie générale de
l'ordre de l'ordre libéral à travers le
monde est une espèce de troublions fou
qui règne sur un pays malade qui est un
pays qui est une secte en réalité une
secte entière donc moi je me suis lassé
de cette hausse est de ceux de cette
façon de renvoyer dos à dos de manière
symétrique donald trump même s'il a les
défauts qu'on connaît et le malade qui
dirige à pyongyang
primo secundo sur sur la sphère qui nous
occupe
imaginez quand même que pour l'instant
la corée du nord possède des missiles
nucléaires à moyenne portée dont ils
sont capables de détruire le japon et
qui sont passés au dessus de ça mais que
le but de ce régime c'est de construire
rapidement des missiles
intercontinentaux de très forte
puissance qui peuvent atteindre l'europe
donc moi je souhaite très vite que
effectivement les américains s'occupe de
ce cas s'en occuper sérieusement et
empêche le dictateur fou qui n'est pas
du tour le rationnel qu'on nous dit ici
de d'aller jusqu'au bout de son
programme d'armement nucléaire
alors on va juste écouter deux secondes
la ministre des armées française
florence parly qui elle prône une
solution diplomatique
pourquoi est-ce qu'au fond on chercha à
prendre des sanctions
c'est parce que nous sommes persuadés
que l'issue de cette situation de
tension extrême ne peut être que
diplomatique et donc avant de parvenir à
nouer un dialogue avec la corée du nord
il faut créer un rapport de force
personne ne trouve la solution est en
fait pas plus trump qu'obama obama avait
été finalement plutôt cool en c1 rien
n'a changé trump a poussé des cris des
hurlements rocket man etc
rien n'a changé non plus il faut
d'ailleurs remarquer que là depuis trois
jours trump a baissé de ton par rapport
à ce qu'il disait il ya quinze jours il
est beaucoup moins violent parce que il
est en train de se dire jusqu'à cette
sortie hier soir oui mais dans la après
ce nouveau domicile qui est comme un tir
de missile balistique intercontinental
il n'arrive pas encore à mettre là la
charge nucléaire sur le missile ils
risquent d'exploser en entrant un procès
en prison ils ont le vecteur ils ont la
charge il faut juste maintenant faire en
sorte que que ça traverse l'atmosphère
on aurait pu imaginer qu'il en kit qui
roadies je vais détruire ce pays
il leur dit c'est parce qu'ils en train
lui même de se rendre compte que
l'invectivé les hurlements bas ça donne
pas grand chose donc quelle est la
solution
c'est forcément comme toujours un
mélange de force et puis à moment maman
faudra faudra discuter mais c'est vrai
que discuter avec un dingo on sait
jamais
comment ça finit car on aimerait savoir
ce que fait la chine
non mais la corée du nord on sait très
bien que pour aller en corée du nord
il faut passer par cette case part la
chine ça les arrange
non je crois pas je suis pas sûr le seul
problème des chinois c'est qu'on sait
très bien que ils veulent pas prendre le
risque que de déstabiliser la corée du
nord parce qu'ils ne veulent jamais leur
pire cauchemar c'est la réunification
des deux corées voilà mai mais là aussi
on dit souvent c'est une assurance vie
qui s'est donnée le korea et puis
maintenant il peut y aller comme les
chinois vont pas tarder à comprendre
qu'il n'est pas bon pour eux de relais
de re faire une ligue entre la corée du
sud le japon les philippines et
différents alliés des etats-unis sur
place qui avait tendance à bifurquer
parce qu'ils n'ont pas surtout les sud
coréens et les japonais ne sais pas
comment c'est pour des raisons
historiques mais en ce moment ils sont
en train de renouer très sérieusement
parce que la menace de corée du de la
corée du nord est une menace ressentie
sur le plan régional de manière très
vive
donc c'est très mauvais pour les chinois
les chinois ont joué effectivement ce
régime malades
la secte qui règne à pyongyang et ça se
retourne contre eux
donc effectivement la solution et
diplomatique diplomatique pas auprès de
pyongyang
ils ces gens-là n'entendent rien ce sont
des malades mais auprès de pékin qui est
là on a affaire à des gens rationnels et
intelligent qui doivent comprendre que
leur intérêt effectivement et d'asphyxié
ce régime pour qu'il arrête mais n'ont
pas non plus intérêt à faire qu'on se
débarrasse de québec ils n'ont ni
intérêt à l'alliance de tous contre
contre eux ni intérêt à ce que le
problème disparaisse et qui arrive donc
il faut qu'ils tiennent comme ça et donc
lui donne un peu d'air cuir mat est
dessus et ça les chinois et ça fait un
essai de gestion des deux solutions
pourrissent couturier a absolument
raison donc fait qu'on doit pas les
mettre sur le même plan mais le problème
des pitreries de tombes c'est que ça
envahi l'espace médiatique et que donc
et ça ne peut pas faire autrement que
vous avez après donc il fait cest witkin
et n'importe quoi qui règne mais on
n'aurait jamais pensé puissent relayer d
d d d absurdité de sites extrémistes
d'un autre pays des choses comme ça
comment voulez vous que ça n'en vis pas
l'espace politique et doux
comment voulez-vous que d'une part ça ne
provoque pas première et fait moins d
espace pour les discussions sérieuses
sur la gravité du problème et
deuxièmement en effet des effets
d'équivalence on a un fouet un autre fou
alors qu'on a un dictateur fou et on a
un président démocrate pitre
c'est qu'il n'est pas la même chose mais
ça provoque ses effets catastrophiques
donc c'est quand même très très mauvais
les trucs de trajet il ya une
politologue américaine qui a dit pendant
la campagne électorale aux états unis
cette chose qui me paraît remarquable
elle dit les électeurs de trump ne le
prennent pas littéralement mais ils le
prennent au sérieux les médias le
prennent littéralement mais ne le prenez
pas au sérieux et je pense que tout est
là nous on se rend pas compte on prend
pour un clown c'est un clown c'est un
pitre évidemment mais c'est donc un
homme politique d'aujourd'hui parce que
les hommes politiques d'aujourd'hui
auront de plus en plus tendance à
ressembler à ça mais le la le cran au
dessus c'est aussi les échanges avec
teresa mais c'est vrai que c'est de
l'inédit total ce côté bas il est clair
que les états unis sous de trump sont en
train d'abandonner leurs alliés
occidentaux essaient d un problème
gravissime pour nous autres en or ce que
nous n'avons pas eu une chance pour
l'europe parce qu'après qu'on va enfin
pourvoir au sein de laquelle votre
défense et gérer une crise aussi grave
est aussi difficile que la corée il
faudrait effectivement une
administration américaine
extraordinairement rationnelle subtil
intelligente et le sait plus très bien
voilà que maintenant là où la rumeur qui
aujourd'hui c'est que trop me virer
tillerson quel patron la diplomatie
américaine qui a eu qui lui-même est
parce qu elles utilisent cela dit si
jamais on a des consignes aux folles on
les applique rythme et donc il part il
semblerait que très bon et maintenant
s'en débarrasser on verra tout cela est
la suite dans le prochain point de vue
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre et à
demain pour un nouveau point de vue
présentée par guillaume roquette
[Musique]